uh how do you want me to bring some
comedy into this show a little bit
yeah i mean we've moved on from brendan
schaub and into comedy
i think that's a good segue you think so
you think
hey welcome to the brown bar my name's
lily how can i help you
i heard a co-worker telling another
co-worker that i'm still saying her name
wrong
i've been working with poor nema for
three years good on you for trying to
learn
it's pronounced ornama listen buddy
buddy you listen
it's protect by the way every person you
see in this video is actually voiced by
hanka's area
not gonna work here anymore how about
that
yes there it is got it mama no i don't
know why my
girlfriend is mad at me 99 of the time
it's not that your brown girlfriend is
defective it's that you don't know how
to treat her right well all i did was
ask her to teach me how to speak indian
where are you
from canada do you speak canadian no i
speak english obviously
obviously oh i get it indian isn't a
language is it there you go
uh what else can i help you with should
i ask her to teach me how oh [ __ ] you
you know what they mean
yeah [ __ ] you if some look if you're
dating some woman and you go hey teach
me you know how to speak indian and they
go
oh actually it's punjab just dump her
she's a
she's a worthless also she's don't marry
her anyway that's going to be a sh
that is going to be a [ __ ] downward
spiral for you
must be hindu sit down i'd like to
return some advice you sold me earlier
uh what was the advice to accept my
son's decision to pursue music
the reason ask the chick from the good
place
it is right for return yeah that's a
trick from the good place
not her to her no that's is it yeah
positive that's a trick from the good
place not looking good you know she's
doing a show with the impractical jokers
now what do you expect
10th one today i got an invitation to my
friend joythe's wedding but i think
there's a typo it says there's four
different events
if this is a real indie cal pen if this
is a real indian place
when this per this he would be following
her around the store
while she shops that's actually sure you
tell me i'm wrong
what are you doing buddy look at the big
mirrors that they have in the corners
pretending to keep putting the same
product why do you keep stocking that
same one bag of doritos that's
my star yeah there is a typo there are
actually
14 different events hi
again how may i help you this time yes
i'm looking for support
for finding a wife for my son are you
single
jay your mom's here again mom you can't
keep doing this
see cause they can make fun of indian
culture
but like isn't this a little
dare i say exclusionary mike it's
very exclusionary but they do say this
is the worst case of being an indian
they've ever seen
i'm depressed and i told my parents i
need to see a therapist but they just
said i need to drink more water you're
gonna need to be more assertive all
right
who's that is that right russell peters
overrated guy
who by the way is like the least indian
of all of them just stop it and overrate
it it might be i know people find him
funny but
i personally i think he's all right i'm
not sure he's fine
whatevs here let's role play a little
bit all right uh lily come here
but okay so let's say you were this
makes it work like why would you do this
hack thing this is such a hack
bit right all i got to say is imagine
the smell in that studio
no no i'd rather not imagine the smell
in that room well it is called the brown
bar
for a second uh i'll be your dad and
you'll be this kid's mother okay sure
okay tell us you need to talk mom dad i
needed to talk about okay shut up we're
busy okay i'll just
just search yourself come on get in
there rj no i need to talk now i need
you to listen no i need you to bloody
listen okay why the bloody hell you're
wearing shoes in the house huh your
mother is asking a question i just
shut up oh that's enough i just knew
more words look i need help
i even found doctors
right they gave her a late night show
mike
this is so this i feel like
i feel like i'm watching remember dat
fan
that's what this feels like you know i i
hate like i hate the fact that this
this [ __ ] wants to be different she
wants to
be the first to a woman of color on late
night she wants to really push the bar
but she's doing hack ethnic material
like this is
this is the that this is you know why i
like bobby lee
because bobby lee's entire act isn't huh
my parents they called me
and if you like bobby lee would suck
that was him bobby
is a legitimate certifiable diagnosable
nut bag
who is funny and who really you know
what i mean like he's a funny guy
especially on a show like he'll really
like dig into your brain and like
you know really get to like the [ __ ]
root of [ __ ] about you and so like
that's why i like him because he's real
but like if bobby lee just went out
there and was like you know when i was
growing up my parents were like oh bobby
ching chang chong chang ching you'd be
like
ah it's another [ __ ] ethnic act hey
you leave that as shane gillis
that's got it covered we don't need that
from you bobby lee
uh well mike she lilly singh
yesterday response about her sexuality
this is a big deal
and today we're going to talk about
let's talk about that paula poundstone
plus issues that's right
that's right twitter starts your engines
now as some of you may know
about a year ago i came out as bisexual
i tweeted out
female colored bisexual right around the
time she got picked up for a show
which time well the first time
right around the first time she came out
of bisexual because i can't tell this
tweet apart from every other tweeter
first
you're right and every other [ __ ]
hack premise and every other monologue
and every other joke and every other
thing is [ __ ]
this [ __ ] one note [ __ ] sh
never said one note lily proven to
be obstacles the brown note but now i'm
fully embracing them as my superpowers
no matter how many boxes you check i
encourage you to do the same and i
really do
the promise a bisexual you've never been
near any boxes you've been with your
long-term boyfriend for 10 years bro
imagine
doing a late night show and constantly
rereading your own empowered tweets
sounds pretty fun to me
huh dude
this is her responding to people making
fun of her watch this is her comeback
watch
that was shot three weeks earlier this
crowd reaction i'm sure coming out was
truly one of the scariest things i've
ever done i thought maybe visiting india
would be worse but you're from canada
how is
it it's 20 20 how is it scary how is it
scary to jump on the side that has all
the momentum
and all the support and all the
background terrifying
and i chose to come out online which is
a great because a great way to get
attention
it's a great way for people to pay
attention to me because i
thrive on it because i am a woman and i
need as much as humanly possible
at every moment and doing it online i'll
get a bunch of
you go girls and hearts if it takes
10 years or 20 years or
50 years no matter how long it takes
i'm gonna say this right now i i will
bitterly hang on to to life
for as long as it takes to watch the
pendulum swing back around
yeah to watch the momentum swing back
the other way
if it takes a hundred years then mark my
words
i will live to be 136 years old
so i can be here for the birth of a new
day
because this [ __ ] is not going to last
way to let people know something
especially if you want to
instantly know exactly how they feel
about you
but as scared as i was i quickly
realized that for every negative comment
i received
i'd get 100 that were super they were
bots
were supportive no they weren't part of
this loving community that was right to
step up
support me and fight the trolls
we have been we have been making fun of
lily saying for a very very long time
as a matter of fact when we started
making fun of lily singh initially when
you would search for her
memeology in our videos would come up
for like you know after her
promoted [ __ ] our videos would come
up we haven't had a lot of people
defending you lily
have you seen a lot of people defending
listening because i have it
it was literally the exact same plot as
harry potter
it's just too bad this didn't happen
you're a bisexual lily
would have made things
we have fans in our i'm embarrassed this
is a network tv
we have fans that listen to our show
that are a million times better would
have done this better than that
in in less than in two minutes time a
lot less confusing
ironically when you have sex with women
though you don't have to worry about
hogwarts
mike she's referring to
getting warts on your genitals
royce if it takes a hundred
years like i know like like
like a ghoul from fallout i will cling
to life
for as long as it takes
that's not that funny no i know royce
they're piping them in it
wasn't even a full year ago i mean this
is all new to me
just like your show you came out at that
very same time i'm still on my learner's
permit
which is great because learning's more
fun when someone else is in the car with
me
aren't you in a long-term relationship
with a guy and been with this dude for a
long time
imagine how cocked he is she feels too
so are you scissoring or are you not
scissoring
but let's be real before i even came out
there were already people in my
community
who just didn't understand lgbtq plus
issues be straight up
they thought a pansexual is someone who
gets horny in the kitchen section of
target
mike no mike no mike no
they say this is the worst case of
bisexuality
that they've ever seen i can't do it
anymore
mike because of target in the pants
section
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i can't do this anymore today a
couple more minutes we're almost there
mike you can do this
we're almost there i can hear her from
over there no put the headphones on
[ __ ] i'm not doing it mike put
the headphones on
no that last one no it's unforgivable
it's unfair
all right you know what i'll just repeat
what she says and to be fair i'm not
even sure what to call my new community
i'm confused too
some people use lgbt plus some use lgbtq
some use lgbtqia or lgbtqiaa
i mean sexuality has more flavors than
baskin robbins
mike good night hey guys have a great
show take care
uh come back you've got a couple minutes
you guys see you guys tomorrow
all right uh day wave tennis stop uh
hippo juice
mike baskin-robbins thirty-one flight uh
revenge of the assist tomorrow
baskin robbins has 31 good night
everyone mike mike
baskin robbins is 31. this isn't even a
bit this time mike baskin-robbins has 31
flavors
mike bye mike baskin-robbins has 31
flavors
well i guess we're done with the show
guys um i just want to say
that that to be fair to mike that's one
of the worst cases of being merch
that he's ever experienced in his life
so we do have to end the show we're
gonna end it there guys that was it he's
screaming through the door
i know he's not coming back he says he's
really not coming back he's yelling
through the door
he's done he's on his phone he's just
done
and thank you for listening guys
goodbye have a great night he's really
mad thank you for listening
uh day wave tomorrow at 10 a.m you got
to be there guys you know miss out
patreon.com we're not sorry uh
newproject2.com i'm going to open up
the i'm going to open up the gesture for
you guys in a second